15 sur public
Sena bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
public Senna c'était l'une des promesses
de campagne de François Hollande
modifier la loi bioéthique de juillet
2011 pour autoriser la recherche sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires ces
cellules ce sont celles qui sont
prélevées sur l'embryon humain au tout
premier stade de son développement des
cellules porteuses d'espoir dans le
traitement de nombreuses maladies graves
comme l'Alzheimer ou encore les
défaillances hépatiques ou cardiaques le
2 octobre la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat a adopté à l'unanimité
moins une voix UMP une proposition de
loi RDSE autorisant sous certaines
conditions la recherche sur l'embryon
porté par Gilbert Barbier le texte en
effet met fin au régime actuel
d'interdiction a sorti de dérogation le
groupe UMP du Sénat rejette ces
propositions pour lui les lois
bioéthique font consensus et il n'est
pas question de revenir sur les
conclusions des états généraux de la
bioéthique pour l'opposition il existe
également d'autres solutions
alternatives comme celle des cellules
souches adultes qui ne portent pas
atteinte à l'embryon pas à la vie
humaine tout en présentant des avantages
comparables à ceux des cellules souches
embryonn alors le Sénat va-t-il
autoriser oui ou non la recherche sur
les cellules souches embryonnaires et
l'embryon en tout cas le débat est
ouvert et c'est maintenant sur Public
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
tendant à modifier la loi 2011 814 du 7
juillet 2011 relative à la bioéthique en
autorisant sous certaines conditions la
recherche sur l'embryon et les cellules
chouches embryonnaires le texte présenté
par Monsieur Jacques mard et les membres
du groupe
RDSE dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Françoise labor de
auteur de la proposition de
loi monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en juin
2011 le Parlement avait eu débattre de
la révision des lois bioéthiques l'un
des points fondamentaux du texte qui
nous était alors soumis concernait la
recherche sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires fallait-il l'autoriser ou
continuer de l'interdire le débat est
récurrent depuis les premières lois
bioéthiques en
1994 le législateur avait posé un
principe d'interdiction absolue estimant
qu'elle portait atteinte à une personne
humaine potentielle
en 2004 il avait maintenu ce principe
d'interdiction mais en avait atténué la
rigueur des recherches sur l'embryon et
les cellules souches embryonnaires
pouvaient être mené à titre exceptionnel
pour une durée de 5 ans sur les embryons
surnuméraires à deux conditions elle
devait permettre des progrès
thérapeutiques majeurs et ne pouvait pas
être poursuivi par une méthode
alternative d'efficacité comparable en
d'autres termes la recherche était
interdite sauf dans les cas dérogatoires
où elle était autorisée en juin 2011
lorsque nous avons eu à débattre de la
question nous étions assez nombreux dans
cet hémicycle à souhaiter passer d'un
régime d'interdiction avec dérogation un
régime d'autorisation
encadré je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le
courage du rapporteur de l'époque alain
Milon pour avoir défendu cette position
avec force il s'agissait avant tout de
mettre fin à une certaine hypocrisie au
terme d'une longue discussion le Sénat a
malheureusement capitulé en deè lecture
au nom de quoi d'une conception
philosophique ou religieuse du statut de
l'embryon ce qui prôent l'interdiction
estime que l'embryon est un être en
devenir et qu'à ce titre la recherche
sur les cellules souche embryonnaire
porte atteinte à la dignité humaine il
fallait dans ce cas l'interdire
complètement
pourquoi l'avoir assorti de dérogation
il y a une logique qui m'échappe par
ailleurs si l'embryon est une personne
humaine potentielle la seule
potentialité ne suffit pas à constituer
une personne humaine comme laa rappeler
notre collègue Gilbert Barbier dans son
rapport le potentiel de vie de l'embryon
n'existe pas en soi il dépend de la
nature et du projet du couple qu'il l'a
conçu ou pour lequel il a été
conçu qui plus est les embryons
concernés par la recherche sont conçus
invitro dans le cadre d'une assistance
médicale à la procréation et ne font
plus l'objet d'un projet parental
autrement dit ils seront détruits on
nous a également objecté à l'époque
qu'il existait une alternative plus
respectueuse de l'embryon les cellules
souches pluripotentes induites les IPs
découvertes par le professeur Yamanaka
qui vient d'ailleurs de recevoir le prix
Nobel de médecine ces cellules souches
sont obtenues à partir de cellules
adultes génétiquement reprogrammé pour
se comporter comme une cellule souche
embryonnaire si ces travaux ont
indéiablement constitué une
extraordinaire avancée scientifique il
est encore nécessaire de pouvoir
travailler en parallèle sur ces deux
types de cellules qui sont
complémentaires en 2004 le manque de
recul dont nous disposions pouvait
expliquer le choix d'un régime
d'interdiction avec dérogation c'était
surtout le moyen pour le législateur de
l'époque de surmonter un dilemme moral
en revanche je ne comprends pas la
position choisie il y a un peu plus d'un
an d'autant que la disposition qui a été
adoptée est bien plus restrictive que
celle de 2004 ainsi la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article L 2151 5 du Code
de la santé publique prévit voit que les
chercheurs doivent expressément apporter
la preuve qu'il leur est impossible de
parvenir au résultats escomptés
autrement c'est-à-dire qu'ils devront
explorer toutes les hypothèses
alternatives même les moins
vraisemblables pour pouvoir obtenir une
autorisation ce nouveau dispositif est
particulièrement ambigu et surtout
impossible à mettre en œuvre nous avons
cooptionné l'immobilisme souhaité par le
gouvernement d'alors ignorant les
propositions suggérées par la plupart
des instances consultatives et les
chercheurs eux-mêmes nous avons opté
pour une révision à minima nous n'avons
pas été à la hauteur des enjeux pourtant
depuis quelques années déjà de nombreux
rapports nous invitai à modifier la
législation pour faciliter le progrès de
la science et de la médecine tout en
garantissant le respect des principes
éthiques
fondamentaux ainsi dans son Bilon de
l'application des loi de bioéthique
remis au ministre chargé de la santé en
octobre 2008 l'agence de la biomédecine
craignait que le régime d'interdiction
ne bloque des projets fondamentaux
permettant des avancées thérapeutiques
et préconisait un régime d'autorisation
pérenne dans son rapport sur la révision
des lois de bioéthique de mai 2009 le
Conseil d'État proposait également de
substituer au régime actuel
d'interdiction à sortie de dérogation un
un régime permanent d'autorisation
encadré par des conditions strictes
c'est également la position de
l'Académie nationale de médecine qui
estime depuis très longtemps qu'il
serait inadéquate et même dangereux
qu'une interdiction de principe soit
maintenue au nom d'un d'un antagonisme
entre recherche et protection de la
vie plus récemment l'OPEX a rappelé
qu'un tel régime était nuisible à la
recherche en France et qu'il stigmati
disaient les chercheurs il a largement
plaidé la levée du moratoire et la
suppression de l'interdiction au profit
d'un régime d'autorisation encadré plus
adapté à la réalité scientifique et tout
aussi protecteur de
l'embryon pourquoi avoir refusé de
prendre en compte les avis de ces
différentes instances le maintien d'un
régime d'interdiction fragilise la
position de la France au sein de la
communauté
internationale notre législation est en
effet l'une des plus restrictives au
monde elle handicape sérieusement les
scientifiques et décourage les
investisseurs étrangers pendant ce temps
dans plusieurs pays européens aux
États-Unis au Japon en Israël au Canada
en Australie la recherche progresse à
grand pas face à cette concurrence nous
prenons beaucoup de retard et le risque
est grand de ne jamais le
rattraper pourtant sur le plan
scientifique il ne fait guerre de doute
que les ch sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires sont porteuses de grands
espoirs ces cellules dites pluripotentes
proviennent de l'embryon humain au tout
premier stade de son développement elles
peuvent se répliquer indéfiniment et se
différencier en plusieurs types de
tissus au cours du développement elles
ont vocation à former tous les tissus de
l'organisme contrairement aux cellules
souches adultes dont l'efficacité s'est
révélée limitée le potentiel
thérapeutique des cellules souches
embryonnaires est
immense un des enjeux majeurs de ces
cellules est la thérapie cellulaire
pardon que l'on appelle aussi médecine
régénératrice cette perspective consiste
à remplacer des cellules endommagées du
fait d'une maladie ou d'un accident elle
pourrait intervenir dans le traitement
des grands brûl des leucémies ou des
maladies génétiques et
neurodégénératives comme la maladie
d'Alzheimer ou de Parkinson il n'est pas
exclu à terme que ces cellules puissent
un jour se substituer à certaines
greffes d'organes les cellules souches
embryonnaires devrait également
permettre aux chercheurs de connaître
des progrès majeurs dans la connaissance
et le traitement des maladies génétiques
et révolutionner la toxicologie
prédictive la recherche doit progresser
et faciliter le développement de
nouvelles thérapeutiques nous ne devons
pas empêcher les équ équipe scientifique
et les malades de mettre leurs espoirs
dans cette voie nouvelle de la science
ils ont déjà perdu beaucoup de temps et
attendre un signal fort c'est l'objectif
poursuivi par notre proposition de loi
nous voulons mettre un terme à
l'insécurité juridique et à l'ambigué de
la loi de 2011 fondé sur une décision
absurde et offrir une meilleure
lisibilité de notre législation dans
l'intérêt de tous je me félicite à ce
titre de la position du président de la
République et de celle de madame la
ministre de la Santé et des affaires
sociales sur le sujet en matière de
recherche sur l'embryon on ne peut pas
faire n'importe quoi c'est là le sens
même du mot éthique c'est pourquoi la
nouvelle rédaction de l'article du code
de la santé publique que nous vous
proposons substitue au régime actuel
d'interdiction assortie de dérogation un
régime d'autorisation particulièrement
en cadré pour être autorisé les
recherches devront remplir quatre
conditions sans lesquelles il ne sera
pas possible de mener recherche je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'à partir du
moment où d'autres recherches offriront
des capacités similaires à celle des
cellules souches embryonnaires la
recherche sur celle-ci sera
interdite je tiens enfin à saluer
l'excellent travail de notre rapporteur
Gilbert Barbier que je remercie pour les
améliorations qu'il a apporté le texte
que nous vous proposons d'adopter n'est
en aucun cas la remise en cause de la
dignité humaine il s'agit avant tout de
donner à nos scientifiques la
possibilité de faire progresser la
recherche médicale et de sauver des vies
je vous
remercie merci Madame Laborde la parole
est à Monsieur Gilbert Barbier
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales
és monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues il y a une semaine le
prix Nobel de médecine a été attribué à
John Gordon et à shinaya
Yamanaka qui à 45 ans de distance ont
démontré d'abord chez la Minin puis chez
l'homme qu'il possible de faire
régresser des cellules adultes jusqu'au
stade de la
pluripotence l'importance de cette
découverte scientifique majeur
aujourd'hui consacré par l'Académie
Nobel n échappé ni aux scientifiques ni
à l'opinion
publique depuis la publication des
travaux du professeur Yamanaka en
2006 plusieurs équipes se sont lancées
dans les recherches sur les cellules
souches induites à la
plripotence
nommé
IPS on entend souvent que ces recherches
rendraient Cadu cell mené sur les
cellules souche embryonnaire humaine car
ces cellules iPS et cellules
embryonnaires auraient les mêmes
caractéristiques les scientifiques que
j'ai auditionné me disent qu'il pour
l'instant ça n'est pas le cas peut-être
se
trompe-t-il mais si demain l'équivalence
est possible alors la recherche à partir
de cellules souchembryonnaire humaines
ne sera plus autorisée en France c'est
expressément ce que prévoit la
proposition de loi que nous examinons ce
soir cette proposition modifie le texte
de l'article 21
515 du code de la santé publique qui a
fait vous vous en souvenez tous sans
doute l'objet de débat profondi dans cet
hémicycle débat intense et parfois
passionnel entre partisans de
l'autorisation de ces recherches et
tenant de leur
interdiction dans un contexte
préélectoral qui n'a pas été sans peser
sur ses choix le gouvernement de
l'époque soutenait qu'il présentait ce
qu'il présentait comme une voie
moyenne en 2004 le principe de
l'interdiction avait été posé et a sorti
de dérogation pour 5 ans le ministre de
la Santé proposait à l'instar des états
généraux de la bioéthique de maintenir
l'interduction de principe de ces
recherches mais de la sortir de
dérogations permanentes à une très
courte majorité cette vision était
finalement celle qui a prévalu au
Sénat la commission des affaires
sociales saisi au fond avait pour sa
part suivi les conclusions de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et
technologiques les conclusions du
Conseil d'État et les conclusions du
rapporteur du projet de loi Alain
m la commission s'était engagée
résolument et de manière
transpartisane dans la voie de
l'autorisation encadrée des
recherches les auteurs de cette
proposition de loi estiment que ce choix
était le bon et nous propose d'adopter
un texte issu des travaux de l'office
parlementaire est très largement
similaire à celui que nous avions adopté
en première et à nouveau en 2uxème
lecture du projet de loi de la
bioéthique
la commission des affaires sociales a
examiné ce texte tant du point de vue
éthique que du point de vue juridique je
note qu'un an après ce texte la
mobilisation des chercheurs et de ceux
qui s'opposent aux recherches sur
l'embryon n'a pas affaibli la question
éthique s'analyse sous deux aspects
faut-il interdire par principe la
recherche sur
l'embron en régime d'autorisation
encadré est-il la voix ouverte à toutes
les dérives
la nécessité d'un interdit symbolique
fort a été souvent invoqué pour
justifier le maintien de disposition
contradictoire au sein de l'article
21515 le groupe de travail du Conseil
d'État que présidait notre collègue
Philippe B avait étudié cet interdit
avant de
l'écarter en effet l'interdiction de
principe de la recherche sur l'embon
n'est pas une garantie éthique
pertinente et ce n'est pas elle qui
offre la meilleure protection contre le
dérive potentiel de la
science pourquoi interdire la recherche
sur
l'embryon parce qu'il est une vie m
potentielle mais ce potentiel de vie
n'existe pas en soi comme l'a rappelé
Françoise labor il dépend de la nature
et du projet du coupe qu'il a conçu et
pour lequel il a été
conçu s'agissant des embryons conçus
dans le cadre de la M qui sont les seuls
visé par l'article 21 515 les embryons
dont un couple peut faire don à la
recherche sont ceux qui sont voués à la
destruction en effet soit ils ne sont
pas implantables en raison d'un problème
affectant leur qualité soit ils sont
porteurs d'une anomalie détectée à la
suite d'un diagnostic
préimplantatoire soit enfin ils ne font
plus l'objet d'un projet parental à
moins d'être donné à un autre couple
l'article 21 41 4 du Code de la santé
publique prévoit qu'ils doivent être
détruit au bout de 50 concervations il
s'agit de faire de la recherche sur des
embryons dont la vocation et la
destruction l'alternative entre
destruction et recherche à des fins de
progrès de la médecine est la seule
ouverte pour décider du devenir de ces
brriillons il me semble que la
possibilité pour les parents de faire
don d'un embryon sain et porteur ou
porteur d'un défaut ou d'une pathologie
pour améliorer le bien-être collectif
plutôt que de laisser simplement
détruire est un choix éthique de la part
de ce couple le texte de la proposition
de loi prévoit la nécessité de confirmer
le don après un délai de réflexion pour
le don des emrion sain et dans tous les
cas la possibilité de révoquer le don
sans motif tant que les recherches n'ont
pas
commencé plusieurs de nos collègues ont
pourtant soutenu que la destruction
était de toute façon préférable afin de
limiter la tentation démiurgique de
l'homme qui souhaite créer la vie et la
modeler selon ses désirs il s'agit bien
sûr d'éviter les dérives de la science
cet objectif nous le partageons tous il
est garanti par le texte de la
proposition de loi en effet le régime
d'autorisation encadré n'est nullement
un droit pour toute équipe de
recherche de mener sans contrôle des
expériences sur l'embryon humain sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires les
équipes de pointe qui élaborent des
protocoles de recherche nécessitant
l'étude de ces embryons ou de ces
cellules doivent déposer une demande
auprès de l'Agence de biomédecine et
obtenir le droit de faire leurs
expériences tel n'est pas le cas pour
les recherches sur les cellules souche d
adulte qui se trouvent dans les tissus
humains ou les cellules orientées vers
un retour aux cellules souche les
équipes qui les utiliseent n'ont de
compte à rendre à aucune autorité
publique je rappelle que l'autorisation
de l'Agence de biomédecine ne peut être
accordé que si quatre conditions
cumulatives sont
réunies le projet doit être
scientifiquement pertinent le texte
prévoit par ailleurs l'interdiction
d'implanter à des fins de G station les
embryons sur lesquels une recherche a
été effectuée et je rappelle que la
création de chimè et d'embryons
transgénique est interdite en
France deuxièmement le projet doit avoir
une finalité
médicale ce qui exclut notamment les
projets avisés
esthétiques le projet ne doit pas
pouvoir être conduit qu'avec des
embryons humains ou des cellules Souch
embryonnaire
humaines enfin il doit respecter des
garanties éthiques
ce qui signifie notamment que l'agence
exerce un contrôle sur la manière dont a
été conçu les lignées des cellules
souschamb ronnaires notamment les
cellules importées de
l'étranger de ces quatre conditions
cumulative la plus contraignante en
pratique et la troisième
elle a pour conséquence que les
recherches sur l'embryon et les cellules
souchambryonnaires n'auront jamais un
caractère
subsidiaire si demain je l'ai dit il
devient possible de mener à partir de
cellules Souch induite le même type
d'expérience que celle possible avec les
embryons humains et les cellules souches
embryonnaires ces recherches seront
interdites c'est l'état de la science et
l'évaluation par un comité scientifique
qui permettent à l'agence de se
prononcer sur cette question chaque fois
qu'un protocole lui est soumis cette
disposition garantit la protection
adéquate de l'embryon telle qu'elle est
prévu par la Convention d'Oviedo sur les
droits de l'homme et la biomédecine que
la France a d'ailleurs
ratifié les chercheurs que j'ai
auditionné soulignent qu'en pratique les
différents types de recherches sont Muné
en parallèle et que les équipes n'ont
pas de parti pris privilégiant la
recherche sur l'embryon
humain je pense que nous pouvons
accréditer cette assertion mais cette
condition est née est lié à la nature
particulière de l'embryon humain et
interprété à la lumière du progrès des
connaissances scientifiques il convient
de le de la
conserver il me semble néanmoins
important de souligner que les
recherches sur l'embryon et les cellules
souche embryonnaire ont aujourd'hui et
sans doute pour plusieurs années encore
une importance centrale pour faire
progresser les connaissan sur le
développement de la vie comme il vient
d'être souligné ainsi que pour la
modélisation des maladie
génétique ainsi que le soulignent les
chercheurs de nombreuses questions de
génétique mais aussi d'épis génétiques
sont posés qui impliquent alternative
crédiible le sans alternative crédiible
le retour aux embryons humains au
cellules souches embryonnairees qui en
sont
issu l'Agence de biomédecine ne se fonde
pas uniquement sur des avis
scientifiques pour prendre ses décisions
son comité d'orientation qui réunit des
scientifiques et des représentants de la
société civile et au sein duquel siège
désormais quatre sénateurs donc votre
serviteur est appelé à se prononcer sur
chaque dossier les considérations
éthiques sont donc présentes pendant
l'instruction du dossier même les avis
de l'Agence sont par ailleurs
susceptible de réexamen à la demande
conjointe des ministres de la recherche
et les ministre de la Santé
enfin l'agence reçoit des rapports
annuels sur les progrès des recherches
et conduit des
inspections le texte a d'ailleurs été
conforté en commission par un amendement
renforçant ses pouvoirs
d'inspection j'en viens maintenant
question de droit le gouvernement
soutenait à l'époque que l'interdiction
de principe à sorti de dérogation et
l'autorisation encadrée était de ce
point de vue équivalente
le juge administratif n'en a pas décidé
ainsi la cour administrative d'appel de
Paris a déduit que l'existence de
l'interdiction de principe qu'il
appartenait à l'agent de la biomédecine
de faire la preuve que des recherche
employant des moyens alternatifs ne
pouvaient parvenir au résultat
escomptés et a en conséquence la cour de
administrative d'appel de Paris a annulé
l'autorisation accordé 3 ans auparavant
à un protocole de
recherche les scientifiques sont en cas
d'annulation tenu d'arrêter
immédiatement leurs travaux sous peine
de sanction
pénale C recours en annulation dont qu
concernent les travaux d'équipe de
l'incerne sont actuellement en cours
d'instruction par le tribunal
administratif de
Paris l'insécurité juridique à laquelle
sont confrontés les chercheurs est le
résultat des ambiguités
de la loi de
2004 cette ambiguité a été accentuée par
le texte voté en 2011 qui consacre cette
ambigué morale et juridique en effet le
texte actuel de l'article
21515 porte la marque de ceux qui à
l'Assemblée nationale à défaut de
pouvoir obtenir l'interdiction des
recherches chercha à rendre quasiment
impossible leur autorisation à force de
conditions en pratique irréalisable
ainsi la nécessité d'établir
explicitement qu'il est impossible de
parvenir au résultat escomptés autrement
et celle d'informer le couple donateur
de la nature des recherches
projetées il n'y a en réalité que deux
possibilités interdire complètement ce
qui peut-être respectable pour un
certain nombre de pensées ou autorisé de
manière encadrée dès lors qué de la
science la recherche sur l'embryon et
les cellules souche embryonnaires est
nécessaire elle doit être autorisée tout
en prenant toutes les précautions
nécessaires afin de garantir l'absence
de dérivve la commission des affaires
sociales en adoptant le texte de la
proposition de loi amendé pour préciser
que les recherches fondamentales sont
possibles et pour renforcer les pouvoirs
de contrôle de l'agence a clairement
fait le choix de la clarté de la
responsabilité
j'espère que notre assemblée en fera de
même je vous en
remercie merci Monsieur Barbier la
parole est à Madame jeuneviè fiorazo
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la
Recherche
merci monsieur le président prident
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur madame la sénatrice Françoise
Laborde Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et
sénateurs je suis heureuse d'être parmi
vous ce soir pour discuter de cette
proposition de loi relative à la
recherche sur l'embrayon et les C
souembrayonnaires humaines nous sommes
aujourd'hui à un tournant important pour
la recherche et la communauté
scientifique mais aussi pour les
patients et l'ensemble des citoyens il
nous revient de trs ce sujet avec le
sérieux la rigueur et toute la toute la
probité intellectuelle et morale qu'il
mérite permettez-moi après l'exposition
de cette PPL et de votre rapport de la
replacer dans sa perspective historique
et
scientifique le contexte historique
d'abord les avancées de la recherche
dans la seconde moitié du 20e siècle ont
rendu possible avec la fécondation
invitro développé dans le cadre de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour Pier la stérilité d'un couple de
produire un embryon commençant à se
développer pendant quelques jours dans
un tube àess in vitro en dehors du corps
de sa mère et avant son implantation
dans le corps de sa mère cette
dissociation à la fois dans l'espace et
dans le temps all les conduire en 1978
en Grande-Bretagne à la naissance de
lwiis Brown puis en 1982 en France à la
naissance d'Amandine ce sont les
interrogations qui ont suivi ce
bouleversement dû aux avancées de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
dans notre pays qui ont conduit au début
de l'année
1983 à la création du Comité consultatif
national
d'éthique la deuxième avancée est la
capacité technique de suspendre le cours
du développement invitro au bout de
quelques jours par le processus de
congélation ou cRIO préservation faisant
aussi disparaître toute notion de limite
de temps a priori entre le moment de la
fécondation et le moment du début de la
grossesse
il existe trois circonstances où ces
embryons créés une vitro par AMP ne
seront pas transférés dans le corps de
la
mer premier cas lorsqu'une anomalie
majeure ou une interruption du
développement d'un embryon est manifeste
in vitro avant l'implantation deuxème
cas lorsqu'au cours d'un diagnostic
préimplantatoire des pays un embryon se
révèle porteur de la séquence génétique
dont la recherche a motiver la
réalisation du
DPI dans ces deux circonstances
l'embryon humain est détruit la troisème
circonstance très différente qui conduit
à ne pas transférer des embryillons
créés une vitro et la décision de les
conserver par cRIO préservation dans le
but d'un transfert ultérieur mais si
ultérieurement ces emryillons cessent
d'être inscrit dans le projet parental
du couple qui a été à l'origine de leur
création la question de l'arrêt de leur
conservation se pose c'est-à-dire la
question de leur destruction c'est dans
cette situation c'est-à-dire celle
d'embryon pour lesquelles il n'est il
est exprimé un abandon du projet
parental ou bien parce qu'il ne peut pas
être satisfait pour des raisons
médicales liées à l'embryon produit in
vitro que la question de la mise à
disposition de cet embryon pour la
recherche est possible la PPL que nous
discutons ce soir s'inscrit totalement
dans ce contexte de plus cette mise à la
disposition de la recherche n'est
possible qu'après une information du
couple et l'obtention de son
consentement venons-en au contexte
scientifique
l'embryon humain apparaît tout d'abord
sous la forme d'une seule cellule née de
la fusion de deux cellules un ovocyte et
un spermatozoïde puis cette cellule va
donner naissance à de nouvelles cellules
et chacune des premières générations de
cellules dites totipotant qui constitue
l'embryon vont conserver une capacité si
on les isole de leur voisine de donner
naissance à elle seul à un nouvel
embryon puis à mesure qu'elles vont
donner naissance à de nouvelles cellules
elles vont perdre cette potentialité et
une frontière va apparaître entre
l'embrayon en tant que tel et chacune
des cellules qui le compose c'est en
1998 20 ans après la naissance de Louis
Brown que sera posé de manière toute
nouvelle la question de la possibilité
et de l'intérêt scientifique de réaliser
des recherches sur des cellules souches
issues d'embriillon humain qui seraient
autrement destiné à être détruits des
travaux de recherche indiquai alors que
les cellules souches embryonnaires
humaines peuvent être isolées et
cultivées in vitro se Renou invitro et
donner des sens invitro en fonction de
l'environnement qu'on leur fournit à la
quasittalité voire à la totalité des
plus de 200 familles différentes de
cellules qui composent le corps humain
adulte ainsi de manière schématique une
cellule souche est une cellule doté à la
fois d'une grande capacité de
renouvellement d'elle-même et d'une
grande plasticité c'est-à-dire une
capacité de donner naissance à des
cellules
différentes pourquoi alors la question
de la recherche sur l'embryon et les
cellules souches embryonnaires
reste-elle d'actu ité et pourquoi
devient-il urgent de passer d'un régime
d'interdiction avec dérogation à une
disposition d'autorisation encadré tout
d'abord la PPS discuté ce soir a pour
objet de modifier une disposition de la
loi de biothique de 2011 et vise à
autoriser sous certaines conditions la
recherche sur l'embrayon et les cellules
souches cette disposition concerne
essentiellement la recherche et ne remet
pas en cause la philosophie générale de
la loi de bioéthique il n'est pas dans
l'intention du gouvernement d'aborder
ici de manière plus générale les autres
dispositions de la loi sur la biothique
ce qui pourrait justifier un débat publ
auquel le gouvernement n'aurait
évidemment pas l'intention de s'opposer
le changement proposé par cette PPL est
significatif quandant à ses implications
pour la recherche et ses retombées
potentiells sur lesquelles je reviendrai
en ce sens le gouvernement souhaite que
le débat puisse avoir lieu de manière
approfondi le temps nécessaire devra y
être consacré la PPL mais mais nous
avons le temps la PPL mentionne la
nécessité pour les chercheurs de montrer
que la recherche nécessite de recourir à
ces cellules souches embryonnaires les
avancées les plus récentes montrent que
nous n'avons pas de réelles alternatives
à l'utilisation de ces cellules souche
pour faire avancer la science avant de
discuter des alternatives potentielles
aux cellules souches embryonnaire
j'aimerais ici préciser que les règles
habituell de la recherche scientifique
conduisent un chercheur à établir dans
son protocole expérimental les
alternatives qui constitueraient une
voie plus efficace et pertinente
permettant d'arriver au résultats
escomptés l'exposer des motifs si j'ose
décrire ainsi le protocole expérimental
fait partie intégrante de l'analyse de
la pertinence scientifique et éthique
d'un projet de recherche quel qu'il soit
en l'occurrence le respect de ces règles
est assuré par l'autorité compétente ici
l'Agence de biomédecine à qui je veux
rendre hommage pour le travail admirable
accompli ces dernières années
admirable et difficile depuis les années
1998 à plusieurs reprises des chercheurs
ont cru pouvoir trouver une alternative
aux cellules embryonnaires ce fut
d'abord la découverte de cellules
souches adules des chercheurs ont
rapporté l'existence de ces cellules
dans la plupart des tissus de
l'organisme la peau la moelleosseuse le
foie ainsi nous pouvons disposer de
cellules souches sans recourir à des
gamettes cependant pour tester leur
propriété il a fallu néanmoins les aux
cellules embryonnaires et leur potentiel
a ainsi été revu à la baisse elles sont
pluripotentes certes mais leur
prolifération réduite et leur
différenciation limitée ne leur
permettent pas de rivaliser avec les
cellules souches
embryonnaires en 2006 et 2007 une
nouvelle avancée a de nouveau pu laisser
croire que la question des cellules
souches embryonnaires était dépassée la
découver avec la découverte des IPS les
cellules pluripotentes induites en
réalité et c'est presque presune règle
en matière de découverte scientifique ce
progrès a soulevé de nouvelles et plus
difficiles questions éthiques deux
généticiens ont découvert que les
cellules spécialisées d'un organisme
adulte pouvaient être reprogrammé afin
de recréer tous les types cellulaires de
l'organisme à l'instar des cellules
souches de l'embryon cette découverte a
d'ailleurs valu cela été dit à Sir John
B Gordon et à chinya Yamanaka de se voir
attribuer la semaine dernière le prix
Nobel de physiologie et de médecine 2012
les IPs pourraient permettre de produire
des modèles cellulaires jusqu'à lors
impossies à créer pour des maladies
génétiques elles offrent la possibilité
de produire n'importe quelle cellule à
partir d'une cellule prélevée sur un
patient ce qui laisse envisager de
nombreuses applications en médecine
personnalisée car elles sont proches de
la réalité physiologique des patients
ces cellules iPS nous dispens-elle pour
autant de recourir aux cellules souches
embryonnaires première difficulté
purement scientifique les IPs ne sont
pas complètement identiques aux cellules
souches embryonnaires l'expression non
contrôlée des modifications génétiques
induites dans ces IPS pourrait entraîner
des cellules cancéreuses IPS nous avons
déjà vu se produire ce type de phénomène
deuxième difficulté sur le plan éthique
ces cellules conserveraient la mémoire
de leur tissu d'origine on voit les
problèmes vertigineux que cela pose si
ces cellules issues de donneurs vivants
étaient utilisées en thérapie humaine
sans parler de leur capacité éventuelle
à être cloné ainsi sur le plan
scientifique nous avons la confirmation
que la recherche a besoin de cette
fertilité croisée basé sur l'utilisation
des cellules souches embryonnaires des
cellules souches adultes et des
IPS c'est l'ensemble des raisons pour
lesquelles les cellules sous
embryonnaires demeurent aujourd'hui le
standard scientifique de référence
d'autre part les autres catégories de
cellules Souch ne permettraient pas les
recherches sur l'embryon intoto
c'est-à-dire sur les premier jour de la
formation de
l'embryon un point maintenant sur le
contexte législatif en France et à
l'étranger vous connaissez comme moi
l'histoire de la législation française
sur la question en
1994 la loi a interdit totalement la
recherche sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires en 2004 contrairement à la
libéralisation attendue l'interdiction a
été maintenue à sortie d'un régime
dérogatoire d'une durée de 5 ans chaque
dérogation est obtenue après
autorisation de l'Agence de la
biomédecine pour des recherches
susceptibles de permettre des progrès
thérapeutiques majeurs faute d'une
méthode alternative d'efficacité
comparable en 2011 la révision des lois
de bioéthique françaises a maintenu le
statut quo décidé en 2004 interdiction
de réaliser des recherches sur l'embryon
ou les cellules embryonnaires tout en
permettant à l'Agence de biomédecine de
distribuer des dérogations qui ne sont
toutefois plus assorties d'une durée de
nombreux pays vous le savez aut au
contraire autoriser la recherche sur
l'embryon et les cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines c'est le cas des
États-Unis du Canada de l'Australie de
la Chine du Japon de Singapour ainsi que
de la majorité des pays européens tels
le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne la Suède
l'Allemagne constitue une des exception
nOTA Dans ce contexte législative les
équipes françaises ont pu cependant
démontrer leur sérieux et leur exence
sur le plan éthique comme sur le plan
scientifique les projets de recherche
présentés depuis la loi du 6 2004 on'ont
essuyé que quatre rejets par l'Agence de
biomédecine 64 projets au contraire ont
été autorisés à ce jour la plupart des
recherches autorisées depuis 2004 a fait
l'objet de publication parfois dans des
revues scientifiques aussi prestigieuses
que nature le Journal of Clinical
Investigation ou molecular and cellular
biology deux projets français touchent à
l'horizon des protocoles d'ESS cliniques
l'un portant sur l'insuffisance
cardiaque grâce à la production de
cellules musculaires du cœur
cardiomyocyte l'autre sur les ulcères de
peau chroniques grâce à la production de
cellules de peau à partir de cellules
souches embryonnaires ceci démontre le
continuum entre la recherche la plus
fondamentale jusqu'au lit du malade
j'aimerais prendre à titre d'exemple le
cas de l'essai clinique sur le
traitement de l'insuffisance
cardiaque l'équipe en est venue à
l'utilisation de cellules souches
embryonnaire après l'échec démontré de
l'utilisation des cellules souches
adultes et 10 ans d'expériment tion la
recherche se poursuit donc en France
mais son potentiel est évidemment freiné
en matière de structuration interne et
de coopération internationale les
restructions de la loi en 2004 comme en
2011 ont de toute évidence freiné les
échanges de savoir et la coopération
scientifique internationale au détriment
de notre pays la France occupe la 8e
place européenne et la 15e mondiale en
matière de publication c'est le résultat
de 7 années de retard par rapport à la
concurrence
cette année sans formation de chercheurs
sans financement de travaux alors que la
Grande-Bretagne en est à son 4è plan de
développement devons-nous dès lors
demeurer isolé dans notre position
pouvons-nous nous contenter d'être
spectateur des progrès de nos
partenaires nous sommes une puissance
scientifique motrice en Europe dans bien
des domaines le président de la
République a souhaité que l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche soit des
leviers décisifs dans le redressement de
notre pays et dans une compétitivité
guidée par la qualité
nous avons un rôle à jouer dans la
construction d'une Europe de la
recherche or la Commission européenne
depuis le 6e Programme Cadre ne nous a
pas attendu pour se mettre en ordre de
marche en soutenant les projets de
recherche sur les cellules souches
qu'elles soient adultes embryillonnaire
fétal ou IPS elle s'est fixé pour
objectif de soutenir les actions les
initiatives qui contribueront à la
coordination à la rationalisation des
lignées de cellules souche embrionnaire
humaine en Europe elle a créé un
répertoire banque de cellules sou
embrionnaire afin d'optimiser
l'exploitation de ligées existantes pour
qu'il soit moins utile dans desrivivé de
nouvelles par destruction d'embryon elle
a de surcroix érigé un code de bonne
conduite fondé sur des principes
éthiques pour définir très strictement
ce qui était permis ce qui ne l'était
pas la France doit-elle demeurer en
retrait notre position est peu lisible à
l'étranger or la coopération
internationale est essentielle dans ce
domaine nos chercheurs doivent pouvoir
collaborer avec nos partenaires étr
pour profiter de l'expérience de pays
plus avancés et bénéficier d'un effet de
levier après 8 années de pratique de
recherche et 64 autorisations dé livré
notre position isolée d'interdiction de
principe assorti de dérogation est-elle
encore
justifiée la question de la recherche
sur les cellules souche et l'embryon qui
est une question très précise à laquelle
nous devons apporter des réponses
mûement réfléchies engage plus
généralement notre vision de la place de
la science dans la
société je dois vous dire que je me suis
forgé une opinion sur cette PPL après
une profonde réflexion j'ai interrogé
les associations de malades et les
chercheurs vérifier son applicabilité
avec l'Agence de biomédecine et discuter
des aspects éthiques avec des membres du
Comité national d'éthique la PPL
proposée par le groupe RDSE permet en
clarifiant le régime juridique de la
recherche sur l'embryon et les cellules
embrionnaire de concilier l'éthique et
la liberté de la recherche nous devons
bien entendu examiner nous-mêm les
enjeux éthique avec toute la vigilance
nécessaire et c'est l'objet du débat que
que nous devons nourrir aujourd'hui de
nos réflexions respectives vous avez su
par ailleurs tout au long de cette
proposition tenir compte de la réalité
de la recherche de ses contraintes de
ses objectifs de sa démarche de son
rythme de ses exigences et votre
compréhension de ces enjeux donne un
sens aux propositions que vous formulez
j'aimerais revenir sur les principes
prises en compte dans cette PPL qui
régissent la recherche sur l'embryon ce
pourquoi elle nous paraît aller dans le
bon sens premièrement la finalité
médicale je prendrai pour exemple
l'attention particulière que vous avez
porté à la nécessité de clarifier
l'objectif de la recherche autorisée
elle doit s'inscrire dans une finalité
médicale et vise à redonner à la
recherche fondamentale toute sa place en
effet la finalité médicale comprend la
recherche fondamentale et appliquée les
progrès de la connaissance ce qu'on
pourrait considérer comme la véritable
finalité de la recherche et la
possibilité d'essayer de développer des
applications éventuellement bénéfiques
ce qu'on pourrait considérer comme l'une
des utilités de la recherche se déploie
dans des espaces temporels différents il
est prioritaire d'essayer de développer
les applications utiles quand elles
deviennent possibles mais illusoire et
dangereux de penser que les applications
futures ne viendront pas d'un mouvement
de
fond d'exploration de l'inconnu et et de
remise en cause en permanence de ces
concepts c'est l'essence même de la
recherche cette recherche s'adresse à
des embryons ne faisant plus l'objet
d'un projet parental je n'y reviens pas
le couple qui fait le don de l'embryon à
la recherche doit être informé et donner
son accord un encadrement des règles
assurant la pertinence scientifique et
le respect des règles éthiques doit être
assuré par une agence qui a la capacité
de diligenter à tout moment un contrôle
de l'avancée de la recherche et des
équipes
enfin les embryillons sur lesquels une
recherche été conduite ne peuvent être
transférés à des fins de
gestation au-dessus de ces principes
cette PPL fait référence dans son alinéa
4 aux principes fondamentaux du Code
civil à savoir la non rémunération le
respect du corps humain la traçabilité
des lignées de cellules souche
garantissant l'information du respect
des règles éthiques cette PPL ne revient
pas sur les règles de transfert permet
uniquement entre des laboratoires ayant
une autorisation d'effectuer des
recherches sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires la nécessité d'obtenir des
autorisations respectif pour
l'importation la conservation des
cellules souches et la recherche ainsi
la PPL discutée aujourd'hui permet de
modifier plusieurs dispositions de la
loi de 2011 qui mettent les chercheurs
et les institutions dans une hypocrisie
qu'il convient de lever passer d'une
recherche interdite par nature mais
nécessitant une dérogation à une
recherche autorisée mais contrôler
revenir sur cette interdiction c'est un
signe fort que vous adressez à la
communauté scientifique en terme de
liberté académique mais aussi aux
malades et à la société la loi de 2011
commande une sorte d'obligation de
résultat aux chercheurs pour lui
permettre de commencer ses travaux la
recherche je cite la recherche est
susceptible de permettre des progrès
médicaux majeur or aucun chercheur ne
peut ainsi s'engager sur l'avenir Serge
Aroche notre tout récent prén noobel de
physique va peut-être permettre à la
France de produire les premiers
ordinateurs quantiques mais il ne
l'aurait jamais promis en engageant ses
recherches fondamentales sur les atome
de ridberg il se garderait bien encore
aujourd'hui de faire une telle promesse
il était scientifiquement
illusoire et par conséquent d'une
certaine façon malhonnête
intellectuellement de laisser croire à
des progrès thérapeutique majeur dès
lors qu'un projet de recherche recevait
une autorisation et qu'elle se situe
bien en amont la finalité médicale doit
être mise en avant mais la garantie de
progrès thérapeutique majeur reste
difficile à définir à
priori ces recherches suscitent
d'immenses espoirs chez des patients
chez des patients atteints de
pathologies graves nous n'avons pas le
droit de susciter de faux espoirs cette
proposition a le mérite de renforcer les
décisions de l'agence d'améliorer la
qualité juridique de cette législation
d'afficher une position claire de la
France quant à la recherche sur
l'embryon et les cellules souches
embryonnaires de replacer la recherche
française dans le réseau international
des chercheurs et de placer les
chercheurs dans une position juridique
moins inconfortable il est maintenant
fondamental qu'un débat puisse avoir
lieu le sujet est suffisamment important
et sensible pour que nous y consacrions
un temps approprié je vous remercie de
votre
attention merci madame la ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame mugaddini pour le
groupe
UCR monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues comme
beaucoup de mes collègues je déplore et
c'est un euphémisme que ce texte Vienne
en discussion un lundi à
22h45 tous ceux qui
étai tous ceux qui étaient présents dans
cet hémicycle juillet 2011 lors de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
bioéthique savent avec quelle gravité et
quelle sérieux la question de la
recherche sur l'embron avait été débatue
et pour débattre gravement et
sérieusement il faut du temps et nous
n'en aurons pas assez ce
soir nos collègues du RDSE le savent
aussi ils ont préféré prendre ce risque
plutôt que ne rien faire et je les
remercie malgré tout de l'avoir pris en
effet je considère que la confusion dans
laquelle nous traitons ce sujet ne peut
plus durer quelques rappels historiques
que je ferai bref parce qu'ils ont déjà
déjà été faits en
1984 la première loi de bioéthique
interdit la recherche sur
l'embryon en 2004 la 2e loi de
bioéthique maintient l'interdiction mais
autorise des dérogations à accordé par
l'Agence de biomédecine en 2011 cette
interdiction est maintenue et la
dérogation soumise de plus à l'accord
des parents d'honneur autant dire qu'on
a essayé de revenir à l'interdiction
absolue et qu'on a de ce fait aussi
tenté d'empêcher toute recherche sur
l'embryon en France et pourtant entre
2004 et 2012 vous l'avez rappelé madame
la ministre 64 protocoles de recherche
sur l'embri
ont été autorisé par l'Agence de
biomédecine et mise en œuvre aujourd'hui
on nous propose d'autoriser la recherche
sur l'embryon en l'encadrant très
strictement quelle différence cela
fait-il sur le fait qu'actuellement en
France des recherches sont faites sur
l'embryon
aucune quelle différence cela fait-il
sur les protocole de recherche beaucoup
les protocoles ne seront pas
automatiquement plus plus facilement
autorisé par l'agence de bio et médecine
mais les délais d'obtention de cette
autorisation seront considérablement
raccourci et les chercheurs français
pourront enfin travailler dans les mêmes
conditions que les autres chercheurs
européen en
particulier pourquoi ce sujet est-il si
sensible bien sûr parce qu'il touche à
l'humain et à la question toujours posée
un embryon est-il un être humain dès sa
conception la réponse à cette question
est totalement personnelle elle dépend
pour chacun de nous de ces conceptions
éthiques religieuses
philosophiques je voudrais seulement
rappeler la définition de l'embryon sur
laquelle la recherche s'effectue c'est
et je cite un amas de 16 cellules
indifférenciés ayant au maximum 5 jours
d'existence autre question d'où viennent
ces embryons la réponse a été déjà
donnée elle est simple et elle mérite
d'être une nouvelle fois rappelée la
recherche se fait sur quelques embryons
non réimplantés dans le cadre des
procréations médicalement
assistés actuellement en France 160000
Ambrons
surnuméraires ne font plus l'objet d'un
projet parental et ne seront pas
réimplantés qui va décider de leur sort
ce sont les parents biologiques à qui on
demande au bout de 5 ans de décider du
sort de leurs embryons ils ont le choix
entre une nouvelle implantation le don
d'embryon à un ou des couples stériles
la destruction ou le don à la recherche
ce sont donc de toute façon cela a été
dit également des embryons destiné à la
destruction qui seront utilisés pour la
recherche il vaut mieux d'ailleurs ne
pas savoir comment sont détruits les
embryons abandonnés par les parents une
de nos collègu ayant eu recours à la PMA
pour la naissance de ses enfants a été
horrifiée quand elle a constaté qu'au
bout de 5 ans ses embryons avaient été
sortis du criot congélateur posé sur un
coin de Paillas en attendant la
décongéation et jeté dans l'évacuation
de l'évier du laborato
la recherche sur l'embryon est-elle
nécessaire
oui car on vous l'a dit également les
recherches sur les cellules
pluripotentes ne permettent pas encore
d'apporter toutes les réponses aux
questions médicales concernant les
connaissance sur le développement de la
vie et les modélisations des maladies
génétiques je peux comprendre et je
respecte mes collègues et ns concitoyens
qui considèrent qu'on ne peut pas
toucher à la vie humaine même à son
stade le plus élémentaire celui d'ambron
c'est d'ailleurs la position de nombreux
collègues de mon groupe mais dans ce cas
interdisons de nouveau totalement la
recherche sur
l'embryon sinon arrêtons cette
hypocrisie et cette supercherie qui
consiste à dire oui en France la
recherche sur l'embryon est interdite
mais quand même des chercheurs sont
autorisés à la faire pour ma part je
souhaite la clarté autorisons la
recherche en étant d'une extrême
vigilance sur les conditions de cette
recherche ce que nous propose le texte
qui nous est soumis ce soir le résultat
sera le même il aura le bénéfice de
cette clarté et permettra à nos
chercheurs de pouvoir enfin travailler à
armes égales avec leurs collègues
étrangers sur des sujets aussi
douloureux et urgents que les maladies
génétiques et les maladies rares entre
autres comme je vous l'ai dit certains
de mes des collègues de mon groupe
voteront cette proposition de loi ceux
dans mon groupe qui s'opposissont à ce
qui s'opposeront à ce texte
s'exprimeront soit avant l'examen de
l'article unique du texte soit lors des
explications de vote sur ce texte je
vous remercie de votre
attention merci Madame diny la parole
est à Monsieur Jean des zessard pour le
groupe
écologie
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi qui nous
est présentée ce jour relance un débat
que nous avons tenu à plusieurs reprises
dans ce même hémicycle débat
particulièrement sensible au Sénat nous
avons à plusieurs reprises voté en
faveur d'une modification des lois sur
la bioéthique pour autoriser et je
précise avec encadrement les recherches
avec l'embryon et les cellules
embryonnaires humaines de quoi s'agit-il
quand on parle de recherche avec des
embryons humains
d'embryons issus de fécondation in vitro
sur numéraire qui n'entre pas dans un
projet parental après consentement des
parents dûent informé de la procédure de
quoi s'agit-il quand on parle de
recherche avec des cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines de cellules
issues d'un embryon non destiné à un
projet parental dans un stade de
développement très peu avancé levons
toute ambigué on ne crée pas des
embryons exprès on n'attend pas à la vie
de qui que ce soit est-ce que les
conditions actuelles de la législation
permettent de mener à bien les
recherches la répon réponse c'est clair
c'est non le fait que ce débat revienne
de manière récurrente et que plutôt que
de trancher positivement on va
d' d' Mo
d'no on va d'hésitation en hésitation
pour finalement arriver à la situation
actuelle bancale incompréhensible
illisible pour ne pas dire R
pourquoi vouloir travailler sur des
embryons ou des cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines parce que pour
certaines recherches à finalité
thérapeutique les cellules souches
adultes ont montré un potentiel limité
leur degré de différenciation est trop
important mais surtout parce qu'ils sont
un support de recherche fondamentale il
est heureux que la rvision de 2011 est
ouvert à la recherche à finalité
médicale donc à la recherche
fondamentale cette recherche
fondamentale est justement celle qui n'a
pas de finalité économique au moment du
lancement des travaux la recherche
fondamentale
n'apparessence pas de finalité ou
d'application immédiate elle vise à
mieux comprendre le fonctionnement de
tel organe tissu cellules les finalités
les bénéfices éventuels sont souvent
insoupçonnés au démarrage du projet de
recherche soit parce qu'on envisage
éventuellement autre chose soit parce
que parallèlement d'autres avancées
scientifiques et ou industrielles ont
permis de voir une finalité à des
recherches qui n'étaient pas destiné à
cela François Jacob dit d'ailleurs que
on mesure l'importance d'une découverte
au degré de surprise qu'elle cause à ce
propos si l'on voulait se garder
justement de dériv mercantiliste nous
devrions peut-être circonscrire à la
recherche fondamentale
quoi qu'il en soit dans notre cas elle a
permis de soutenir trois types de
recherches celle visant à comprendre
comment se transforme les cellules
embryonnaires pour devenir spécialisé
celle visant à comprendre les mécanismes
de survenue de maladie celle visant à
tester l'efficacité ou la toxicité de
médicaments mais dans le même temps le
texte adopté en 2011 a maintenu
l'interdiction à sortie de
et a cadenassé les possibilités
d'accéder à ces dérogations en adossant
à la demande l'exigence de démontrer
qu'il n'existe aucune autre alternative
de recherche c'est la contrainte dit de
non
comparabilité il est très difficile
financièrement et techniquement de
conduire des études préalables sur
toutes les populations cellulaires
alternatives dans le seul but d'obtenir
un résultat né
justifiant secondairement une demande de
dérogation pour des cellules Souch
embryonnaires et en plus de la
difficulté pratique de démontrer une
telle assertion c'est méconnaître les
fondements même de la recherche
fondamentale bref on ouvre d'un côté
pour refermer de l'autre si bien que
dans la pratique c'est juste
inopérant de fait la procédure
d'obtention de la dérogation est un
parcours du combattant comme vous le
savez c'est l'Agence de biomédecine qui
en qui a en charge l'étude des demandes
elle décide pour chaque année civile de
période de dépôt des demandes et doit
donner sa réponse aux demandes dans les
4 mois suivant la clôture de la période
de dépôt la compatibilité avec la
procédure de demande de financement par
l'équipe scientifique peut interroger
d'autant que les organismes sollicités
peuvent être refroidis par le manque
d'assurance vis-à-vis de l'obtention de
la dérogation entre une équipe qui peut
faire les recherches et une équipe qui
peut peut-être faire les recherches
entre un projet sûr de pouvoir se
réaliser et un projet suspendu à une
procédure potentiellement remise en
cause le choix paraît vite fait d'autant
que contrairement à ce qu'on nous
soutient il n'y a pas équivalence entre
interdiction avec dérogation et
autorisation encadrée dans la mise en
œuvre il y a une différence juridique
ainsi avec une interdiction de principe
il revient à l'Agence de biomédecine qui
délivre les dérogations
de faire la preuve qu'aucune méthode
alternative ne pourrait permettre
d'aboutir au résultat escomptés mais le
principe du en l'état actuel de la
science est diversement apprécié et des
personnes ou organisations défavorables
au recherche ont au fait d'attaquer
l'agence pour des dérogations qu'elles
ont accordé qu'elle a accordé faute de
pouvoir faire la démonstration attendu
l'agence a dû annuler des autorisations
qu'elle avait accordé tout cela ne donne
pas confiance à nos partenaires et
n'aide pas nos scientifiques à rattraper
les retards accumulés les retards sur
les travaux ont entraîné des retards sur
les acquis la formation les compétences
la Constitution d'équipe opérationnelle
la crédibilité vis-à-vis de partenaires
scientifiques et ou financier la prise
de responsabilité la France en est à sa
première génération de responsables
alors que les États-Unis en sont à leur
3è on est donc entré dans un cercle
vicieux duquel se la décision
d'autoriser les recherches avec
encadrement nous permettra de sortir
c'est pourquoi comme lors des précédents
débats au Sénat les sénatrices et
sénateurs écologistes voteront cette
proposition de loi je vous merci merci
Monsieur desessar la parole est à
Monsieur Alain Milon pour le groupe
umpoup
bien monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission des Affaires social monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je suis heureux heureux de
pouvoir à nouveau débattre d'un sujet au
combien important pour la recherche même
si je déplore comme beaucoup de mes
collègues que le jour et l'heure de la
séance ne permettent pas à bon nombre
d'entre eux de participer à ce débat je
tiens à d'abord que je m'exprime en mon
nom personnel ce qui vous en
conviendrait est tout à fait légitime
sur des sujets qui engag la conscience
de
chacun je constate pour m'en réjouir que
le groupe RDSE a repris la quasi
totalité des dispositions que j'avais
proposé en 2011 au moment de l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à la bioéthique à
mon grand regret ce texte n'avait pas
passé le cap de la séance le Sénat ayant
voté conforme en deuxème lecture celui
de l'assemblée qui prévoyait une
interdiction de la recherche sur
l'embryon et les cellules
schembrionnaire assorti de dérogation
permanentes c'était prendre à la légère
le rôle du législateur et je n'ai pas
changé d'avis sur ce point depuis
l'année dernière l'un des enjeux
fondamentaux de la révision des lois de
bioéthiques de 2011 était la recherche
sur l'embryon et les cellules souches
ronire je l'avais affirmé lors de nos
débats le texte adopté à l'époque était
et j'en suis toujours convaincu en
régression par rapport à la loi de 2004
à mon sens il cumulait nombre de travers
reprochés aux lois contemporaines
ambigué juridique dispositions
incantatoire et conditions impossibles à
remplir la loi révisée en 2011 à de fait
mis l'accent sur trois contraintes qui
ont donné des armes à certains ennemis
déclarés de la recherche il s'agit de la
contrainte de la pertinence
scientifique celle de l'intérêt médical
majeur et enfin celle de la non
comparabilité la pertinence scientifique
paraît à première vue tout à fait
indispensable et je suis comme d'autres
de mes collègues le premier à la
réclamer dans tous les travaux
scientifique malheureusement il existe
un côté
pervers qui vient de coûter plus de 9
mois de retard dans l'un des programmes
majeurs celui qui concerne l'autisme un
programme que nombre de scientifiqu
Français souhaittre aborder au travers
de formes familiales qui compte pour à
peu près 1 % des patients ce qui
représente vous en conviendrez un nombre
non négligeable puisque l'autisme touche
selon les épidémiologistes 1 % des
enfants plusieurs gènes ont été
directement associés à ces formes
familial notamment par des chercheurs de
l'Institut Pasteur une demande de
dérogation a été
rejetée dans un premier temps parce que
et je cite l'autisme n'était pas
considéré comme une maladie
monogénétique ce qui est une véritable
bêtise scientifique que beaucoup
contestent l'intérêt médical majeur a
heureusement remplacé en 2011 l'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur mais demeure un
levier efficace pour ceux qui souhaitent
bloquer la recherche sur l'embryon cela
a été le cas pour l'un des programmes
l'an dernier qui portait sur des
cellules présentant une une mutation du
gène APC les patients porteur de cette
mutation déclenche des cancers digestifs
mais aussi d'autres atteintes plus
subtile parmi cellees-ci les
scientifiques s'étaient intéressés à
étudier les mécanismes d'une
prolifération anormale de cellules
rétiniennes parce que cela permettait de
rechercher des étapes précoces des
dysfonctionnements associés à la
mutation ce que bien évidemment ne ne
permettent plus les études réalisées sur
les cellules cancéreuses dans lesquelles
les désordres sont déjà trop important
le conseil d'orientation a refusé
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas
d'intérêt médical majeur puisque les
études ne s'intéressaient pas
directement à ce qui tue les patients
pour l'instant ce programme est donc mis
de côté la non comparabilité
c'est-à-dire l'obligation qui est faite
de démontrer qu'il n'existe pas
d'alternative à l'utilisation des
cellules souches embryonnaires est un
peu l'arme ultime contre les recherches
il est évidemment impossible
financièrement et techniquement de
conduire des études préalables sur
toutes les populations cellulaires
alternatives dans le seul but d'obtenir
un résultat négatif justifiant
secondairement une demande de dérogation
pour des cellules
souchambrionn ainsi le texte de 2011
contredisait en outre la position de
l'Académie de médecine comme elle comme
elle le rappelait dans son rapport du 22
juin 2010 et je cite interdiction de
principe de toute recherche sur
l'embryon ne peut-être justifiée par la
protection d'embryon qui n'ont pas
d'autre avenir que l'arrêt de leur vie
de façon plus générale il allait à
l'encontre des fondements communs à
toute démarche scientifique en effet
dans le cadre d'une démarche
scientifique les chercheurs apprennent
ils apprennent par l'expérience et ils
apprennent par l'échec il me semble faux
de prétendre qu'un type particulier de
Cell souche offre aujourd'hui des
perspectives supérieures aux autres pour
la recherche si cela était vrai il
faudrait interdire toutes les recherches
à l'exclusion de Cell sur les cellules
souches purépotentes induites pour
mémoire il s'agit de Cellu souchadite
mais tout le monde l'a déjà dit ici et
de type quand même
OGM d'ailleurs comme le soulignait le
professeur péchansski dans une
publication en date du 31 mar mars 2011
et je cite à nouveau il est en parallèle
souvent compliqué d'interpréter des les
des résultats obtenus à l'a des à l'aide
des cellules souches génétiquement
modifiées qui ne reproduisent que
partiellement les caractéristiques
physiologiques en tout état de cause les
difficultés associées à la diversité
induite par le désordre épigén génétique
dans les ligé IPs nous oblige à les
utiliser avec beaucoup plus de prudence
et de contrôle que les ligées
embryonnaires les cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines se caractérise
par deux propriétés physiologiques qui
permettent de de surmonter ces obstacles
elles sont capables à la fois de se
diviser à l'infini en laboratoire et une
fois mise dans les conditions requises
de se spécialiser dans tous les types de
cellules de l'organisme elle donne ainsi
accès à des cellules parfaitement
physiologique dans la qualité voulue
quel qu'elle soit et dans le type voulu
quel qu'il soit l'intérêt de C de ces
cellules est renforcé par l'accès ouvert
par le diagnostic préemplatatoire à des
cellules souches embryonnaire humaine
porteuse d'une lésion du génome
responsable de maladie génétique fin de
citation en 2011 au cours des débats
j'ai régulièrement entendu dire pour
justifier qui est l'interdiction avec
dérogation que l'interdiction de
principe était en continuité avec les
lois bioéthiques de 2004 or je rappelle
que l'interdiction de principe mise en
place en 2004 avait été assortie de
dérogation temporaire alors qu'en 2011
nous avons acté un principe général
d'interdiction à sortie de dérogation
permanentees ce faisant nous avons
prétendu concilier de principe
incompatible à mon sens cela revient à
refuser de trancher cela revient à ne
pas vouloir assumer ses choix les
raisons essentielles pour lesquelles
j'étais opposé au textes adopté par le
Parlement sont toujours valabl mes chers
collègues inscrire que les recherches
alternatives aux recherches sur
l'embryon doivent être promu et que les
parents doivent être informés de
l'utilisation des embryons donnés à la
science relève de l'idéolog
mais pas du droit mettre en place un tel
régime d'interdiction avec des
dérogations particulièrement ambigus et
renoncer à établir des règles simples et
compréhensibles par tous revenait à nous
dessaisir de notre mission de dire le
droit et à déléguer cette lourde tâche à
l'Agence de biomédecine dont la mission
n'est pourtant pas de découvrir notre
intention cachée derrière les
contradictions et les
domimots par ailleurs il aurait été
infiniment préférable de faire œuvre de
pédagogie et d'expliquer en quoi
consistent les recherches sur les celles
souches embryonnaires et sur l'embryon
nous savons que ces recherches ne
peuvent être effectuées que jusqu'à 5
jours après la fécondation si nous
l'expliquions en français il serait
certainement mieux disposé envers ses
recherches pour dire encore plus
clairement les choses j'estime que la
loi de 2011 élude les questions que les
Français se posent elle n'est qu'un
rideau de fumée permettant de cacher à
l'opinion l'absence de position claire
du Parlement sur ces questions je
réaffirme que l'encadrement de
l'autorisation qui permettra de
préserver la dignité humaine dès le
début de la vie bien plus que le régime
hybride confus et incohérent que nous
avons mis en place je
respecte beaucoup
ceux qui ont défendu l'interdiction
totale car cette interdiction totale
avait au moins le mérite de lever toute
ambigué l'autorisation encadrée telle
qu'elle est prévue dans le texte de la
proposition de loi et non pas une
autorisation de principe mais une
autorisation sous conditions strictes et
cumulativ en dehors desquelles la
recherche ne peut avoir lieu si l'une
des conditions n'est pas remplie la
recherche n'est pas
autorisée je terminerai m chers
collègues mon propos en affirmant ce que
j'avais dit dans le cadre d'une
discussion que j'avais eu avec un
sénateur de de la majorité
d'alors en affirmant que je crains les
régimes où la loi dicte la vérité
scientifique mais je craindrai bien
évidemment tout autant les régimes ou la
science dicteraient le droit même si je
n'en connais pas ou du moins pas encore
pour toutes ces raisons mes chers
collègues vous l'avez compris je voterai
d deux bras des deux mains si j'avais le
droit cette proposition de loi qui est
présentée par Gilbert
Barbie merci mon cher collègue la parole
est au président Bernard casazo pour le
groupe
socialiste
monsieur le
Président Madame le
Ministre Mons le rapporteur mes chers
collègues c'est avec conviction que le
groupe
associe à la proposition de loi de
monsieur le sénateur Jacques mzard et de
Madame Laborde puisque semble-t-il il
faut rendre à César ce qui lui
appartient je remercie à cette occasion
Monsieur Gilbert Barbier pour son
rapport il correspond exactement à ce
que nous pouvions attendre et c'est pas
tous les jours mon cher Gilbert que j'ai
l'occasion de vous en
féliciter d'habitude c'est plutôt le
contraire
l'article concernant la recherche sur
l'embruyon a souche emuyonnaire a été le
plus discuté de la loi du 7 juillet 2011
on l'a dit en première lecture il y
avait eu un texte consensuel sous la
conduite
courageuse de d'Alain billon qui vient
de s'exprimer il levait l'hypocrisie de
l'interdiction de principe la recherche
sur l'embryon en France et d'ailleurs
cette décision fut
saluée pendant très peu de temps
malheureusement par la communauté
scientifique malheureusement dès sa
deuxème lecture au Parlement le
conservatisme l'avait emporté aussi bien
sur cet article que sur le reste du
projet
d'ailleurs certains
ajouts établis à l'Assemblée
nationale ont rendu encore plus
difficile le travail des chercheurs en
ce domaine proposition de loi qui est
aujourhi examiné reprend cont tenu
amendé de l'article 23 du projet de loi
bioéthique adopté en première lecture au
Sénat il propose dans un article unique
de remplacer le dispositif juridique
actuel d'interdiction à sortie de
dérogation par celui de recherche
l'embron et les cellules
schambrillonnaire dans un régime
d'autorisation encadré en cela ce
dispositif renoue en fin de compte avec
la philosophie de l'article 19 du projet
de loi bioéthique défendu à l'époque par
le gouvernement Jospin en
2001 qui légalisait d'ailleurs l'étude
scientifique sur l'embryon il est
regrettable nous ayons perdu entre-temps
11 ans l'enjeu n'est pas modeste du
point de vue du droit la majorité
précédente soutenait avec fort que
l'interdiction de principe à sorti de
dérogation et l'autorisation encadrée
était de ce point de vue équivalente
nous disions alors que ce ne serait pas
le cas
l'actualité judiciaire nous a donné
raison et Gilbert Barbier en a parlé je
ne reprendrai pas donc les décision des
cours administratives d'appel de
Paris qui ont
pendant qui sont en train d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui de discuter d'un certain
nombre de recours en annulation et ces
recours qui ont mis les chercheurs dans
dans une insécurité
juridique à laquelle ils sont confrontés
et que que nous comprenons bien n avons
donc l'obligation de réagir maintenant
en approuvant ce texte de loi sur ce
sujet notre position a toujours été
constante et
cohérente nous sommes partisans de
l'autorisation encadrée de la recherche
sur l'embbruon et les cellules Souch
embruonnaires point celles-ci intéresse
scientifiques et médecins parce qu'elles
sont capables de proliférer indéfiniment
on l'a dit donner naissance surtout à
n'importe quelle cellule spécialisé de
l'organisme d'où leur nom de totipotente
en un mot ces cellules sont ainsi les
meilleurs outils de la médecine
régénératrice dans la lutte contre les
maladies
dégénératives en dépit des craintes
qu'elles peuvent susciter les
perspectives de la recherche sur
l'embryon humain demeure aujourd'hui
pour l'essentiel du domaine de la terra
incognita on peut toutefois observer que
dans les pays où des travaux sur les
cellules souschambrionnaires sont depuis
quelques années déjà
autorisés les programmes engagés ont
permis de produire des résultats très
prometteurs j'en veux pour preuve le
procédé du bébé double espoir l' esppoir
d'être indamne d'une maladie génétique
familiale et l'espoir de guérir par une
grève de cellules souche contenu dans
l'ENSEM du cordon de l'ANC frères ou
sœur malade en 2000 l'année naissance
aux États-Unis d'Adam dont les cellules
souches de moelle avaiit permis de
sauver sa sœur molie 6 ans atteint de la
maladie de fanconie représentait un
formidable espoir pour soigner des
enfants atteints de pathologie incurable
or il a fallu 6 ans pour que cette
technique soit partiellement autorisée
par l'Agence de biomédecine dans notre
pays 11 ans pour que la France accouche
en 2011 d'un bébé conçu par ce procédé
bébé prénommé
humut le professeur René Friedman
d'ailleurs dit
que si dans les conditions si dans en
1982 lors de de de la
mise de la naissance d'Amandine il il
avait eu les
contraintes qui se sont passé par la
suite et bien cette opération n'aurait
jamais pu avoir lieu alors certes nous
disent les opposants d'autres techniques
existent comme celle basé sur les
cellules souches
pluripotentes dou plupotent stem cells
ou
IPS fabriqué à partir de tissu génétique
adulte et le prix Nobel d'ailleurs on
l'a dit je le répète pas quoi qu'on peut
répéter son nom chin Yamanaka néanmoins
qu'oublie de dire les partisans
intéressés de l'IPS c'est que ces succès
récents ont été rendus uniquement
possibles par les connaissances
accumulées dans le cadre de la recherche
sur les cellules d'origine embryonnaire
même les chercheurs travaill travaillant
sur l'IPS nous le disent et pour cause
nous disposons de 31 ans de retour
d'expérience sur ces sur ces dernières
de 6 ans seulement pour les IPs les
scientifiques s'accordent tous pour nous
rappeler l'insuffisance du recul
nécessaire pour évaluer ses eff les IPs
la faiblesse de son rendement et son
coup faramineux c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi les laboratoires scientifiques
partout dans le monde ont centré leur
activité de recherche prioritairement
sur les cellules souche
enembyonnaire dès lors la seule question
de bon sens qui doit être présente à
notre esprit sur ce texte est la
suivante nos chercheurs ont-ils
aujourd'hui la possibilité de lutter à
armes égal dans le domaine des
biotechnologies médicales
ou bien devrons-nous nous contenter de
payer dès à présent pour notre santé des
royalty aux industries américaines
japonaises ou autres la réponse a trop
tardé l'histoire de la recherche sur les
cellules Souch embbruyonnières humaines
est en France marquée par le combat que
mènent contre elle les lobes
antiscien opposé à toute atteinte à ce
qu'il considèrent comme un être humain
de la fécondation
ils se sont successivement opposés au
cours des années au droit des femmes à
l'avortement à la procréation
médicalement assisté puis au test de
dépistage génétique avant de de de
s'attaquer au aux cellules souches
adopté sous leur pression les lois de
bioéthique 94 2004 et 2011 ont exclu la
France de l'élan scientifique
international
autour des cellules souschambronnaires
notre pays pour le pour le moins
pourtant était dans le trio de tête
mondiale de la recherche jusqu'au début
des années
1990 aujourd'hui le poids de l'idéologie
rétrograde et la frilosité des pouvoirs
publics ont abouti à l'immobilisme dans
notre pays nous sommes omnubilés par le
statut de l'embron c'est un tabou et
comme vous le savez derrière ce m se
cache souvent l'idéologie et
l'hypocrisie ça a été démontré par les
uns et les autres avant moi on a ainsi
créé une situation ubuesque où la
recherche sur l'embbrouyon est interdite
sauf dans les cas dérogatoires où est
autorisé et encore lorsque les
chercheurs respectent les conditions
préalables quasi impossibles à
remplir le vote de ce texte va libérer
la recherche de notre pays et donner au
chercheurs un autre espoir à nos
concitoyens pour demain je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président la
parole est à notre collègue monsieur gu
ficher pour le groupe
CRC monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mes chers
collègues l'examen par notre haute
assemblée de la révision des lois
bioéthique
séclair du prix Nobel de médecine qui
vient d'apporter des perspectives au
sujet dont nous débattons ce
soir
avec mes collègues du groupe CRC bien
entendu je m'étais opposé au projet
défendu par l'ancien gouvernement à
savoir le maintien d'un principe
d'interdiction de la de la recherche
embrionnaire à sortie d'éventuelles
dérogations avec d'autres au-delà des
rangs de la gauche je pense notamment à
celui qui fut notre rapporteur d'allors
alain
Milon qui très
courageusement avait porter un texte qui
honorait la position de la Commission
des affaires sociales et nous avions
soutenu le principe d'une autorisation
encadrée de la
recherche une voix qui faut-il le
rappeler était celle retenue à la fois
par l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques et par le Conseil
d'État ayant soutenu cette démarche au
sein de notre commission et en séance
publique vous comprendrez naturellement
qu'aujourd'hui notre
groupe le groupe CRC comme il l'a fait
il y a un an vote en faveur de cette
proposition de loi nous sommes
constants ce vote mes chers collègues
repose sur les deux principes
fondamentaux et incontournables contenu
dans ce qui deviendra je l'espère le
nouveau régime légal une recherche
autorisée mais une recherche
encadrée le basculement d'un régime
d'interdiction avec dérogation vers un
régime d'autorisation encadré mais fin
et je crois que cela a été déjà
fortement affirmé par Madame la Ministre
notre rapporteur et au sein de
commission l'autorité de notre
présidente an David et bien met fin à
une situation absurde inefficace et
hypocrite nous le savons tous et les
scientifiques que nous avons auditionné
en 2011 l'ont témoigné dans les fait
toutes les demandes de recherche formulé
dès lors qu'elle ne soulevait pas de
problèmes éthiques et qu'elle
poursuivait une finalité thérapeutique
était à titre dérogatoire autorisé
certains voudrai d'ailleurs prendre
prétexte de cet argument pour ne pas
basculer vers un régime d'autorisation
encadré or nous nous le
savons cela a fait perdre du temps au
scientifiques français et à complexifier
leur
pratique mais elle est aussi hypocrite
et d'une certaine manière jette sur les
scientifiqu qui conduisent des
recherches sur l'embryon une suspicion
permanente une suspicion qui n'aura plus
demain si cette proposition de loi est
adoptée plus de raison d'exister car les
critères d'autorisation qui sont prévus
sont tout aussi importants et
contraignants que les critères qui
existent déjà et cela est bien normal
lorsque l'on mesure à la fois
l'importance de ces recherches sur
l'avenir de la santé humaine et ce sur
quoi elle
porte toutes les conditions sont réunies
pour que que demain aucun scientifique
ne puisse se comporter comme un apprenti
sorcier je pense notamment disant cela à
la règle qui voudra qu'aucune recherche
ne soit menée si celle-ci n'est pas
pertinente et n'a pas de finalité
médicale les recherches sur l'embryon et
les cellules souches embryonnaires parce
qu'ell portent en quelque sorte sur les
prémisses de la vie humaine ne doivent
avoir qu'un objectif faire en sorte que
les F US de ces recherches profite à
l'humanité toute entière en ce sens que
les recherches apporteront des réponses
à des patients qui ne bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'aucun traitement efficace
je fais d'ailleurs toute confiance à
l'agence de
biomédecine je pense également à la
disposition qui prévoit que la recherche
sur l'embryon et les cellules souches
embryonnaires ne doivent pas être une
finalité en soi mais une possibilité
offerte à la science à un moment donné
si demain des recherches identiques
peuvent être nommé menées sur d'autres
modèles notamment animaux alors cette
recherche sera privilégiée à la
recherche
embryonnaire j'en viens enfin à une
autre condition qui m' paraît être la
plus
fondamentale celle de la limitation de
la recherche aux seuls embryons sur
numuméraire et ne faisant plus l'objet
d'un projet parental beaucoup l'ont déjà
dit comme le soulligne d'ailleurs le
généticien Axel can l'embryon est une
potentialité de vie certains voient en
lui la vie quand j'y vois pour ma part
c'estes prémisses une
possibilité bien que ne partageant pas
la vie de mes collègues je le respecte
et je crois que toutes et tous ici
convenons malgré nos différences que
contenu de la singularité d'embryon il
faut le respecter mais ce respect ne
doit pas conduire à exclure la recherche
car si le fait de conserver congeler un
embryon sur numuméraire pendant
plusieurs semaines voire des années ne
lui retire pas sa potentialité
biologique de devenir un être humain il
faut encore pour qu'il le devienne qu'il
fasse l'objet d'un projet parental
c'est-à-dire qu'un couple décide de
faire en conscience d'une matière
possiblement humaine un enfant or les
recherches dont il est question ici ne
porteront que sur des embryons qui ne
font pas l'objet d'un projet parental
c'est-à-dire qui sont voués tôt ou tard
à perdre toute potentialité humaine
cette proposition de loi mes chers
collègu me semble équilibré
elle est garant d'avancé scientifique
tout en maintenant un cadre éthique de
nature à protéger les convictions de
toutes et tous elle pose le principe
d'un régime d'autorisation dont je suis
convaincu à la lecture du dispositif
juridique prévu qu'elle contient les
conditions suffisantes pour éviter les
Herms que certains craignent elle
permettent également et je sais que nous
y sommes au-delà de nos différences
particulièrement attaché à empêcher la
marchandisation de
l'embryon la loi réaffirme le principe
de l'interdiction de la fabrication
d'embryons qui n'aurait pas initialement
de finalité humaines seuls les embryons
surnum
pourront être utilisés il ne pourra donc
pas être fabriqué d'embryon comme on
fabrique des tissus humains ou des amas
de cellule afin précisément que
l'embryon ne soit pas réduit à une
structure alors chosif fiable ça me ça
me va pas ça mais vous m'avez compris à
cet égard et parce que le groupe CRC
partage la position de l'un de nos
philosophes Lucien sè philosophe et
ancien membre du comité consultatif
national d'éthique qui
affirmait que la façon de traiter
l'embryon engage
inexorablement la façon de traiter
l'humanité nous considérons que les
conditions et garanties qui sont posé
dans cette proposition de loi sont
réunis pour permettre le développement
d'une recherche profitable aux hommes et
respectueuse de l'humanité donc nous
voterons cette proposition de loi
merci merci Monsieur ficher la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno rotaillot pour le
groupe
UMP bien monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre moi non
plus je ne me déjugerai pas par rapport
au vote que j'ai pu émettre il y a 1 an
et je voudrais
aborder au début ce texte qui est un
texte assez essentiel essentiel au sens
étymologique du terme en insistant en
premier lieu sur deux remarques qui me
paraissent préalable la première
remarque c'est pour m'étonner de ce que
j'appellerais une sorte de bougeotte un
peu législative puisque ce texte qui est
un texte sur un sujet grave où nous nous
sommes certes opposés où nous avons
débattu toujours avec beaucoup de
respect et je suis heureux de voir aussi
ce soir dans quel état d'esprit les uns
et les autres sont mais franchement mes
chers collègues nous avons voté ce texte
il y a 1 an un texte qui avait donné
lieu à une très grosse préparation en
terme de forum de publication d'audition
un texte qui a donné lieu ici à des
débats qui avaient été longs qui avaient
été serrés qui avait été vif mais qui
avait été encore une fois de très grande
qualité et voilà que tout juste juste un
an après le vote de cette loi encore une
fois sur un sujet qui devrait mériter un
peu de Constance tous les sujets ne sont
pas de ceuxl et bien il faille remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier nuitamment à la
sauvette et je trouve que au moins sur
le plan de cette forme là nous
conviendrons que on aurait pu le faire
dans des conditions de débat beaucoup
plus sérieuses je voudrais mes chers
collègues m'étonné quand même euh de
cette instabilité juridique je crois
qu'il y a au moins une chose qui peut
nous réunir sur tous ces B c'est combien
combien de fois avons-nous déploré qu'en
France il y avait trop de lois trop de
règlements et que pire euh ces lois
changeaient perpétuellement et bien je
crois qu'on tombe si je dire un peu dans
dans le panneau et que non seulement
pour ma part je pense que et d'autres
l'ont assuré avant moi que trop de lo lo
tue la loi mais je pense queun forme
d'instabilité normative est une mauvaise
chose pour l'esprit public d'autres
l'ont dit là aussi avant moi et puisque
je parle aussi juste en dessous de la
statue de Portalis je voudrais vous
rappeler ce que Portalis disait sur les
lois existantes il faut toucher aux lois
existantes qu'avec une main tremblante
c'est la première remarque préalable la
seconde c'est que la loi que nous avons
voté il y a un an a un article qui est
l'article 46 qui dispose que euh toute
réforme de ce texte et ce sera l'objet
précisément de la déclaration préalable
de mon collègue Dominique de leège et
bien que toute réforme de ce texte doit
donner lieu lorsque cette réforme a une
portée éthique et celle que vous
proposez là bien évidemment à un débat
public euh la loi précise même la forme
du débat public puisque la loi dit un
débat public sous la la forme d'État
généraux non seulement il y a pas de
débat public mais il y a un moignon de
débat franchement encore une fois à la
sauvette en catimini ça ne peut pas non
plus nous satisfaire et là aussi chers
collègues quelle force peut avoir
l'autorité de la loi si nous-même
finalement nous ne respectons pas la
lettre de la loi que nous avons voté il
y a 1 an je pense que on pourrait aussi
méditer cette remarque de forme alors
maintenant je voudrais en venir au fond
pour formuler trois objections une
objection d'ordre général une objection
d'ordre un peu plus pratique et une
objection d'ordre éthique la première
qui est une objection d'ordre général
c'est que si j'ai bien lu l'exposé des
motif du texte on nous convoque ce soir
parce qu'il y a des impatiences
scientifiques j'ai entendu les uns et
les autres dire mais la communauté
scientifique la communauté scientifique
nous demande de légiférer bien mais ça
n'est pas comme ça que le Sénat
fonctionne d'abord il y a-t-il une
communauté scientifique j'ai relevé et
vous avez pu relever aussi que la
communauté scientifique n'est pas une
sur cette disposition là vous avez en
tête un certain nombre de professeurs
qui ont émis des avis qui sont
différents par rapport à d'autres
professeurs par ailleurs le Sénat ça
n'est pas une chambre d'enregistrement
de ce que telle ou telle communauté
fussent-elle extrêmement experte nous
demande de voter
je pense que la science bien entendu est
un facteur extraordinaire de progrès et
il faut s'en louer mais je pense en même
temps que ça ne doit pas conduire à une
forme d'emballement d'une forme de
grande machinerie là
aussi monsieur Auguste Comte est très
âgé si j'ose dire il y a eu un siècle de
différence qui nous sépare de de lui et
ce siècle nous a montré que même les
scientifiques les plus éminents doivent
aussi se soumettre à des conditions
éthique sans lesquelles le progrès la
science ne peuvent pas travailler à
l'intérêt de l'humanité ou de
l'humanisme c'est la première objection
que je voudrais formuler la deuxième me
semble-t-il elle est plus importante
elle est d'ordre pratique on nous a dit
jusqu'à présent écoutez il n'y a pas de
vraies alternatives il n'y a qu'une
seule alternative c'est le travail sur
les cellules souches embryonnaires
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont noté ici à
cette tribune avant moi il y a une forme
d'extraordinaire coïncidence puisque il
y a 8 jours très exactement
effectivement le prix Nobel de médecine
a été attribué à deux chercheurs dont un
chercheur japonais le professeur
Yamanaka pour ses découvertes sur les
cellules souche adulte pluripodante
reprogrammé indiquer que ces découvertes
n'ont rien donné sur le plan concret
médical c'est faux vous savez que elles
ont permis d'ailleurs Marie Thérèse l'an
dernier nous l'avait très bien exprimé
expliqué ici elles ont permis de
modéliser une douzaine de pathologies
bien Axel CAN qui avait été alors il y a
un an auditionné à l'Assemblée dans le
cadre de la préparation du texte avait
indiqué que c'est sans doute une des
méthodes les plus prometteuses pour les
besoins de la médecine régénérative et
il concluait aucune recherche sur
l'embrion n'est donc nécessaire dans
cette perspective donc vous voyez que le
débat n'est pas aussi simple en terme
scientifique qu'on veut bien nous le
proposer et je pense qu'en réalité on
voudrait nous inciter à franchir une
limite anthropologique alors que il
existe bien des solutions des solutions
d'ailleurs que donne le texte puisque le
texte n'est pas une interdiction totale
c'est une interdiction avec des
dérogation mais d'autres pistes de
solutions qui sont parfaitement valables
celles du professeur Yamanaka que je
viens de citer sur la reprogrammation
des cellules souche adulte humaine mais
celle aussi qui n'a pas été pour
l'instant citée madame la ministre
celles aussi qui sont nées de
l'utilisation des cellules issues du
sang de cordon et plac interre là aussi
elles donneent des fruit puisque d'ors
et déjà actuellement concrètement plus
de 3000 malades peuvent bénéficier de
ces pistes qui ne posent aucun problème
d'ordre éthique je voulais le souligner
la trisème objection elle est d'ordre
éthique passer Jean Desessard l'a dit et
je le rejoins sur ce pointlà passer d'un
régime d'Inter addiction avec des
dérogations à un régime d'autorisation
encadré ça n'est pas du tout la même
chose c'est une inversion même radicale
d'autant plus radicale cette inversion
que comme je le disais justement euh
aucune nécessité scientifique absolu ne
vient la justifier la question qui est
sous-jacente là encore d'autres
intervenants qui m'ont précédés l'ont
indiqué la question qui est sous-jacente
à notre débat c'est quand est-ce que on
devient un être humain il n'y a pas
d'accord entre nous sur les différents
bancs au sein d'ailleurs de nos familles
respectives politiques et il n'y a pas
cet accord sur le moment particulier où
on franchit le seuil de la vie où on
franchit le seuil de l'humanité et
mugadini a eu parfaitement raison pour
indiquer que cette questionl seule notre
conscience personnelle peut parvenir à
la trancher est-ce que pour autant il ne
peut pas y avoir de consensus je pense
qu'il peut y avoir un consensus déjà il
y a une forme de convergence de
jurisprudence ou de texte je veux citer
par exemple la définition que le Comité
consultatif national d'éthique avait
donné de l'ambryon en indiquant que
l'embrayon est une personne humaine
potentielle c'est-à-dire en quelque
sorte que chaque étape de son
développement était comme contenu dans
l'étape précédente avec cette idée d'un
continuum à avec des ruptures qui sont
bien malaisé à installer dans dans au
sein de ce continuum il y a aussi la
convention internationale
d'Oviedo qui insiste sur la protection
adéquate que doivent bénéficier les
embryons en matière de recherche il y a
plus récemment encore le jugement de la
Cour européenne de justice récent
puisque il date du 18 octobre 2011 il y
a tout juste 1 an qui exclut toute
probabilité des techniques de recherche
précisément quand elle elles ont eu pour
préalable la destruction de l'embron
donc on voit bien que les choses encore
une fois ne sont pas simples qu'un
certain nombre de textes de
jurisprudence nous amène à poser la
question finalement est-ce que l'embryon
doit être respecté effectivement et je
pense que en parlant de consensus ou
d'accord nous pourrions de façon ultime
peut-être nous rejoindre en indiquant
que s'il n'y a pas de certitude et on le
voit bien il ne peut pas y avoir des
certitudes alors abêtons-nous derrière
le doute le doute puisque certains
philosophes ont été cités tout à l'heure
je voudrais citer Alain le doute n'est
pas au-dessous du savoir disait Alain il
est au-dessus du savoir et en
l'occurrence le doute mes chers
collègues n'est-il pas une raison
suffisante pour nous abstenir de traiter
l'embryon comme un simple matériau de
laboratoire sachant que pour ma part je
pense que il n'y a rien à perdre à
laisser la loi telle qu'elle est puisque
vous l'avez vous-même madame la ministre
la plupart des demandes d'ailleurs ont
fait l'objet d'un accord de l'Agence de
biomédecine je pense que nous n'y
perdrons pas en revanche je suis sûr que
si on ne vote pas ce texte nous y
gagnerons beaucoup c'est-à-dire que nous
y gagnerons sur une transgressession
anthropologique qui ne me paraît
absolument pas utile merci de votre
attention merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Michel bon dernier
orateur
inscrit
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues certains nous disent qu'il n'y
a pas lieu de légiférer sur les
embryons que les recherches sur les
cellules Souch embrionnair n'ont plus
d'utilité
autoriser les recherches ne serait plus
d'actualité au prétexte qu'un chercheur
japonais le professeur
yamanakin prix Nobel de médecine
2012 a découvert une alternative à
l'utilisation de ces cellules souches
provenant des
embryons selon le professeur Yamanaka
les cellules souches
spécialisé pourrait être
reprogrammé c'est-à-dire transformé en C
nul souche non spécialisée pour devenir
plus ripotente
elle serait donc dotée de la capacité de
se différencier en plusieurs types de
cellules les résultats de cette
recherche sont à
l'évidence très
prometteurs mais
aujourd'hui les scientifiques sont une
anime pour dire qu'ils sont dans le
doute ils ne peuvent garantir que les
cellules adultes reprogrammées sont
rigoureusement identiques aux cellules
suches
embryonnaires les analyses comparatives
entre les deux types de cellules n'ont
pas encore permis de conclure au
caractère identique de ces deux cellules
les chercheurs ont donc encore besoin de
travailler sur les cellules Souch
embryonnaire pour progresser et faire
avancer la science dans ce domaine
dans sa rédaction
actuelle
l'article
21515 du code de la santé
publique interdit les recherches sur
l'embryon et les cellules souches
embryonnaires tout en instituant un
régime de
dérogation cette proposition de loi vise
à substituer à ce principe
d'interdiction avec
dérogation un principe d'autor
strictement
encadrée entre ces deux principes le fil
peut paraître ténu il est en fait lourde
conséquence car c'est au juge
administratif qu'il est revenu au final
de juger de la pertinence des programmes
de recherche sur les sououche
embryonnaire dès lors que l'Agence de la
biomédecine ne pouvait apporter la
preuve que des recherches loi voyant des
moyens alternatifs ne pouvait parvenir
au résultat
escomptés mais comment
l'agence pouvait-elle apporter cette
preuve sinon à considérer que la
découverte précède la recherche ce n'est
pas au juge de dire ce que doit être la
recherche scientifique pas plus que ce
rôle n'appartient au
législateur responsabilité du
législateur consiste à exiger que toutes
les précautions soient prises à fixer
les limites à prévenir et si nécessaire
à pénaliser les dérives la
responsabilité du juge est de garantir
le respect de la loi ni l'un ni l'autre
non vocation à se substituer aux
chercheurs pas plus qu'ils n'ont à se
prononcer pour établir ce qui est une
vérité scientifique et ce qui ne l'est
pas Albert Einstein a écrit la
personnalité
créatrice doit pouvoir penser et juger
par elle-même car le progrès moral de la
société dépend exclusivement de son
indépendance nous approchons là ce qui
fait le fondement même de la recherche
la science n'est jamais F
comment concevoir qu'il puisse exister
une recherche sans qu'il ne soit accordé
aux chercheurs la liberté de chercher
c'est-à-dire de penser de créer on ne
peut trouver que s l' on est libre de
chercher le rôle du législateur est de
permettre la disposition de permettre de
mettre pardon le rôle du législateur est
de mettre à la disposition des
scientifique le cadre légal strict mais
protecteur qui leur est nécessaire pour
déployer leur recherche en bénéficiant
de cette confiance citoyenne sans
laquelle il n'est pas d'avancée
scientifique
partagé le devoir du législateur est
donc bien d'offrir aux acteurs de la
recherche cette liberté dont ils ont
besoin pour faire progresser la
connaissance et dans le cas qui nous
préoccupe ce
soir d'inventer les thérapies qui demain
permettront de faire reculer la maladie
car il convient toujours de distinguer
la science des usages qui peuvent en
être faits si la science est libre les
usages doivent être
réglementés car deux principes demeurent
intangibles le respect de la dignité
humaine
et la non marchandisation du
vivant mais le rôle du législateur est
aussi de veiller à ce que toutes les
précautions soient prises car il ne
serait pas raisonable il ne serait pas
acceptable d'autoriser des pratiques qui
relèveraient plus d'apprentis sorciers
que de chercheurs scientifiques personne
ne conteste que les cellules Souch
embryonnaires humaines présentent une
singularité qui tient à leur nature
il ne s'agit pas là d'une matière
organique
inerte d'un simple has cellulaire mais
bien de cellules issues d'embryon
humains conçu lors d'une fécondation inv
vitro dans le cadre d'une procréation
médicale
assistée faut-il pour autant considérer
que ces embryons et ces cellules souches
embryonnaires doivent être doté d'un
statut particulier
conviendrait-il de les protéger dans
leur intégrité comme dans leur dignité à
l'instar de toute personne humaine la
réponse à ces questions fait débat pour
ma part on ne peut revendiquer un statut
de personne humaine pour un embryon qui
ne s'inscrit pas dans un projet parental
ce qui est le cas des embryons
surnuméraires qui rappelons-le ont
vocation à être détruit conformément au
Code de la santé publique en effet après
5 ans de congélation si les parents ont
renoncé à leur projet parental les
cellules sont
détruites n'y aurait-il pas la matière
au-delà des sensibilités philosophiques
et religieuses qui peuvent parfois nous
différencier à substituer au concept de
projet parental qui ferait défaut un
concept de projet sociétal avisé médical
ou thérapeutique c'est sur la base de ce
consensus qu'il paraît désormais
possible d'autoriser sous condition les
recherches sur l'embryon humain et les
cellules souche embryonnaire humaines
dès lors que celles-ci s'insrivent bien
sûr dans une finalité médicale voilà
pour la proposition de loi RDS
autorisant sous certaines conditions la
recherche sur Bron nous y reviendrons
bien entendu plus largement dans
d'autres journal de 19h mais en
attendant tout de suite la bibliothèque
mdic avec bonne matinée à
vous